i like this one i dig it
i got this off tick tock um
it's just a simple message but it's an
important one let's play it it's about
cheating and instagram
he says if a girl is your girlfriend she
is your main woman and she's advertising
her body on the internet for other men
to look at that is [ __ ] cheating i
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody says
okay so wait a second i just need
clarification on this because uh he says
girlfriend main woman am i to assume
that there's the girlfriend that's the
main woman and then there's the side
pieces
for him quite possibly if i'm not
mistaken he's got several women in his
life okay and let me comment on that too
like to me that would not work i'd be
like
see you see when i see you but
if some women are okay with that
everybody's got their own situation
right so you can you can judge some
people judge sometimes i judge but
they're going to do what they want to do
right if you go to a girl and you say
hey listen um i'd like you to be my main
squeeze but i also don't want to be
faithful i want to have x y and the girl
says cool i don't care all right
whatever it's not my business right
you're not dating me it's not my
business
so what's interesting about that video
is about instagram and cheating
i would be curious what his opinion is
of is it cheating then if a guy
gets on instagram and and goes into the
gym half naked some guy's going to the
gym half naked especially in miami i
noticed
and takes pictures and posts them is
that cheating because obviously you know
you put that up maybe that guy maybe
that guy's not looking for attention i
don't know maybe he's whatever but is
that cheating is it cheating if a guy
i'm trying to think of a corresponding
situation right a woman all dressed up a
woman in bikini a man all dressed up a
man in a swimsuit is that considered
cheating or is there a double is there a
double standard here is there a separate
set of rules i'm deeply curious because
i find that in a lot of circumstances we
did a video with um
what's his name the other day uh
what's his name we just talked about it
entertained the other day and we said um
he said there was a separate set of
rules for men and women aren't you so
i'm curious is there a separate set of
rules so let's just say this is not
cheating
that's not cheating
cheating
needs requires some type of interaction
okay now if that girl
went on in your girl right your your
main squeeze whatever went on instagram
and posted a photo and then people were
writing and she responded with like
heart emoji or dm'd them or responded in
a way that was flirtatious that's
different that would to me that would
not be cool that's not how you behave
when you have to me that's not how you
behave when you're in a relationship
okay but has to go both ways right
for me has to go both ways
you demand respect you
give respect now i will say this to some
of the ladies on the gram though if you
have a man and you're out like
two things always rub me the wrong way
tyler i'm gonna be honest
if a woman is going out with a guy and
that's her boyfriend and you know she's
going out with a guy and then she goes
on the gram and you don't see that guy
anywhere the guy is nowhere to be found
that's weird to me
why
like it looks like on your page you look
single but we all know you're either
married or you've got a boyfriend he's
nowhere to be seen okay you're playing
some type of game i want to see your dms
what's going on in there what are you
trying to solicit what are you trying to
send a message out that you're single
but you're really not but you're still
filtered that looks to me like you're
not you're not set on that relationship
you do something dirty is going on same
for guys by the way if you're a guy you
have a girlfriend and your whole page is
just about you and you can't tell you
have a girlfriend okay in your mind you
don't have a girlfriend let's be real
let's call spade what it is
uh but it's not cheating it's gotta be
cheating involves interaction
okay but so you've got a girl right yeah
and she's in a bathing suit and she's
got the carousel or whatever you know
three pictures right she's got one from
the front one from the back and one from
the side and she's showing it all off
but she's got a boyfriend what is the
point of that
some girls do that because i'm gonna
tell you i had this conversation with
adam and i know none of you guys in the
room believe me i don't know if eric was
here but none of the guys in the room
believe me sometimes
it depends on the type of woman
sometimes for example i will take photo
and i'll be like wow i had a good day i
look good today doesn't happen today's
not one of those days by the way
but some days i'll be like oh i look
good today this is i'm proud of this i
went to the gym this week i'm looking
tight boom i'm not looking for i'm
married i'm not looking for
oh hey baby i'm not looking for any of
that i'm not a cheater never been a
cheater not interested
so
it's about like hey
this is me i look good i feel good great
and they post it but they're not they're
not but also
what does the rest of the pages look
like do you draw a distinction between
taking a picture of something like you
look good but you're like you say
buttoned up as opposed to the girl who
is blatantly flaunting
i think there's a difference i think you
have to look at the totality of what's
going on on for instagram for example
what's going on in the page like you
look at my page i have a bikini pic at
one point it's not constant it's not
constant it's not like you see this and
you see this and i'm lifting this up and
then i'm lifting that down and it's like
not all about that you see pictures of
my baby on there you see pictures of
show content you see stuff about my
husband it's a total package
if i see a page where a woman is you
know
doing sexy stuff oh like that's the
whole page that's their motivation yeah
they're probably looking for something
and there's no guy on there so they're
probably looking for something something
right it depends you gotta look or maybe
they're just i don't know maybe they're
proud of what they got going on it just
seems a little weird i don't know but if
the bottom line is if you've got a man
if you've got a man or you've got a
woman and they don't exist on your page
but all that does exist on your page is
you showcasing some type of goods that's
a problem i'm not cheating though i
don't see that as cheating if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
you